-Guys, it is time
for the latest edition
of our "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Polls ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This first poll asked,
"What is the greatest threat
facing America today?"
10% said Iran,
10% said North Korea,
10% said Russia,
70% said, "Dads joining TikTok."
-Oh.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I agree.
This next poll asked,
"Are you drinking enough water?"
40% said,
"I could be drinking more."
40% said, "I think
I'm drinking the right amount."
20% said, "What percentage
of White Claw is water?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-This next poll asked, "Where do
you watch 'Mare of Easttown'?"
25% said, "On my phone."
-Mm.
-25% said, "In my home."
[ Laughter ]
25% said, "While eating my
hoogie and drinking wooder."
[ Laughter ]
And 25% said, "Not sure why
yer being so newsey,
but I'll prolly watch
after getting con-fra-bill
in the baff-room."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next one asks,
"What are your summer plans?"
2% said, "Going to the beach."
2% said, "Visiting my family."
96% said, "Trying to remember
what it feels like
to be around other people
without having a panic attack."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This next poll asked,
"How do you think Joe Biden
is doing as president?"
70% said,
"I'm really pleased so far."
29% said, "I think
he's doing a horrible job."
1% said, "Now listen here, Jack,
I once knew a guy named
Spitshine Johansson.
He used to shine your shoes
so good you could see if someone
coming in the reflection
was a friend or foe.
And if it was a foe,
you could kick him in the crotch
before he gotcha!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
So specific.
-Next poll asks,
"What's your favorite thing
about charcuterie boards?"
25% said,
"They look great on Instagram."
20% said, "Everyone can eat as
much or little as they want."
55% said, "They're basically
adult Lunchables."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They basically are.
-White Claw and a Lunchable.
-The next poll asks,
"Who do you think committed
the murder in the documentary?"
40% said, "The husband."
[ Laughter ]
20% said, "But I didn't even
say which documentary."
40% said, "Doesn't matter.
It was the husband. Trust me."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And the last poll asked,
"Who's your favorite member
of Biden's cabinet?"
100% said,
"I'm gonna be real with you.
I don't know a single member
of Biden's cabinet,
and I've never been happier."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "Tonight Show Polls."